Hi, I'm Dr. Kevin Conners and this video is simply to invite you to my online newsletter by signing up at the box there put your name and your email.
I don't do practice management. I don't sell things. I'm not trying to sell anybody anything.
But I got confronted a while back by a friend of mine who said, you know, if you die all the information that you have dies with you, you need to share it with people.
And I thought about that a little bit and I thought, well, there's a lot of truth to that.
That the smartest person on the planet, there's a lot of brilliant doctors that you can learn a lot from.
But I just want to share my expertise and my clinical tidbits, I guess, that could help you in practice.
I graduated from Northwestern Chiropractic in 1986, practice chiropractic for years.
But sometimes God has a different plan. We left chiropractic and spent some time in Mexico doing full-time missionary work.
My family and I came back to chiropractic and then God really started to reveal his different plan for us.
Cancer patient came to me. I was practicing chiropractic. That was totally out of my scope of practice.
But said that if I wasn't able to help her nutritionally that she didn't have any other hope, basically.
So that's what I started digging. And God just let me doubt a path to finally give up my license and don't practice chiropractic at all anymore.
And help people with just chronic diseases, cancer, Lyme disease, chronic autoimmune issues, but mainly cancer.
That's what this newsletter series mainly focuses on. And I know that's beyond your scope of practice. I'm not trying to tell you to practice a certain way.
But there's a lot of people out there that are really sick. That you know what? They come in your office and you might not know what to do with them.
So if you could just pick up some little tidbits from my newsletter, it could be a help. That's all I'm trying to do.
We get that selling anything so there's nothing to buy. But I am available for you to talk to if you have questions about difficult patients.
Feel free to call me by office and I'll call you back and just want to help.
So I hope this is a blessing to you. Feel free to sign up. If you don't like it, unsubscribe. There's no catches or got they involved.
Thank you. And I hope it's a blessing to you. Bye-bye.